first how to chop an onion this is the
root that's absolutely crucial leave
that on there if you cut that off the
onion will start to bleed and you'll
start crying rapidly
slice going forward let the weight of
the knife do the work three fingers
one in front two behind and this part of
the knuckle is going to guide the knife
fingers on top of the onion point the
knife towards the root and try to get
as close to the root as possible nice
long
stroke
and then push the onion back together
push the knife halfway in to the onion
slightly tilt the knife down
one at the top
and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in place
with the weight of the blade to cut
through that onion to get to the base of
the root
again turn it round up and down motion
and that's what we left there no waste
just the root
and look
there
you've got a really nice finely chopped
onion
basmati rice the king of all rice is
light fluffy delicious and i'm going to
show you how to cook it perfectly
now
start off with
400 grams of rice rice in
spot on
so what i'm going to do now is just
rinse off the dust and the starch
cold water always
[Music]
and just rinse
the rice that stops the rice from
becoming clumpy in the pan and allows it
to become really nice light and fluffy
once it's cooked rice
into the pan now to make a plain fluffy
rice exciting we're going to infuse it
three cardamom pods
and just get the pods and just pierce
them so it allows all that flavor to
come out
cardamom pods
and then
star anise now these are beautiful whole
star anise
it makes it really nice and fragrant
salt and pepper a lot easier to season
the rice now
than it is once it's cooked you start to
break it up when you season once it's
cooked now basically
one part rice to one and a half part
water
600 mils always start off in cold water
cold water in
onto the gas
lid on
bring it up to the ball as quick as
possible and turn it down and let it
simmer for eight to ten minutes and
that's the secret behind cooking great
rice allow it to steam as it's cooking
do not lift that lid up
lid off
[Music]
it smells aromatic basically all the
water's absorbed the rice has doubled in
size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the staranise out
the cardamom pods they all should have
risen to the top
pods out
take your fork
fluff it through
basically it just sort of starts to open
back up
once you've forked it through it becomes
really nice and light and fluffy and
there
that is perfectly cooked rice
this is basically a filleted side of
salmon it's been taken off the bone and
now
skin off
pick up your knife a really nice broad
flexible
affinity knife
a little sharpen
lift up
the base of the towel and then just nick
a little bit at the end there twist the
knife
almost as if it's horizontally
underneath the salmon pull
the skin and you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work now get your skin
flip it back over
and check you're not leaving too much
salmon on top of the skin
pull it back
nice and slowly get the skin wrap it
around your fingers
pull the salmon towards you
and then just all the way through
lay that down
one
nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snakeskin
[Music]
get your knife
and just run the knife down
and then
with a pair of tweezers these are fish
tweezers but you can use normal tweezers
look for the head
up
and pull
and with the skin being removed from
underneath the salmon
the pin bones come out a lot easier
and the pimples only go
to just basically halfway
along the fillet
one nice
fillet of salmon
beautiful
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife sharpen it before and every
time you use it first grip the steel
feel really comfortable about holding
the still imagine you're holding a
tennis racquet or you're playing squash
you've got to be really comfortable with
it now 45 degrees confident grip
confident grip with a knife this is the
butt of the steel really important to
keep your fingers behind there you never
grip a steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the
blade over steel
stroke
and we start from the bottom to the top
so there
across
there
across
slow strokes over the top of the steel
and then come back underneath then back
in the knees
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now
that's ready to start chopping
it can be easily undercooked or
overcooked here's how to do it properly
first water in nice large pan to make
sure the pasta's got sufficient room to
cook evenly nicely seasoned absolutely
crucial
olive oil in
that stops the pasta from sticking
together
bring it up to the ball
that's the rolling boil the secret there
it stops the pasta from sticking
together and it gently rolls it around
now this is angel pasta nice thin
pasta takes three and a half to four
minutes so into the pan as it hits the
water it melts and then you turn it
round tongs as that starts to melt
gently twist that into the pan bring it
back up to the boil if you're bad at
timing then set a timer
beautiful
to test it
lift a little strand
and you can actually feel it with your
fingers it's still nice and firm
al dente not a bite not a strong bite
but just really nice and firm inside
definitely not crunchy and then
into a colander drain the pasta
in
a light seasoning
salt
and pepper
a tablespoon
of olive oil
mix that through
that stops it from sticking together
and look
there you go beautiful pasta al dente
cooked perfectly let's give a little
rinse
okay and
let's get cooking them shall we
there's a big one